So I don't really speak about this topic anymore on here, um,
for my own reasons,
although I have spoken about it in the past.
But this week,
it has just been confirmed that Israel
how to target missile strike on the World Central Kitchen.
And if you've been following along with any of my commentary
on this issue,
you know that my heart and my stances with the civilians
and just the egregious,
flagrant disregard for innocent human life that is happening
is astounding.
And I don't need anybody in my comments tell me, like,
whose fault it is,
because there's very impassioned opinions on both sides.
You know, which came first,
the chicken or the egg?
But what is clear to me is that Israel is not taking into account
whatsoever the human life cost,
which makes me believe that they do not value
gods and lives the same way.
And Hamas, who is responsible for this current escalation of violence,
made absolutely no plans
for the safety or well being of the Palestinian people.
No one here gives a shit about the people,
except maybe World Central Kitchen.